one senator who is speaking out against
all this florida senator marco rubio
senator you actually said about this i
found it interesting that joe biden the
administration the doj the fbi are
playing with fire
look i'm here in a very unique position
in south florida surrounded by people
that come from countries where this is
familiar to them this is shocking to
americans but in latin america and many
of these you know countries around the
world here's what happens a group takes
power one of the first things that group
does is they begin to persecute and go
after their political opponents and then
when the supporters of their political
opponents begin to complain about it
they begin to target them and they
criminalize opposition and that's what's
happening here now they took power they
are demanding and you see it on twitter
you see their public statements they are
demanding they want donald trump
arrested they want him charged right now
they wanted him charged
months ago years ago they wanted him
charged and i'm telling you the next
thing you're going to see here sean
because it's the playbook and that is
they are now going to begin to say oh
these trump supporters these republicans
they're very upset they're saying very
angry things we think they might be a
threat we think they're radical
extremists let's start arresting them
you're going the next step in this
process is going to be that people who
are supporters of donald trump or just
conservatives complaining about this are
going to begin to get harassed by are
going to begin to get labeled as
potential insurrectionists and are going
to begin to get harassed by law
enforcement that's the next step in this
playbook sadly
you know we went through three years
senator three long years where we now
know that fisa warrants were obtained
using an unverifiable
dirty russian dossier that was bought
and paid for by donald trump's opponent
in 2016 hillary clinton and all of that
information was false and even andrew
mccabe the deputy director of the fbi
said without that dirty dossier there
wouldn't be any fisa warrants but yet
they used it four times even when the
sub source for christopher steele
acknowledged none of it was true there
were no hookers in the ritz carlton in
moscow urinating on donald trump's bed
which was part of this crap this went on
for three long years i believe the fbi
and i believe the department of justice
have squandered any good will or any
any deserved trust of the american
people especially when it comes to
donald trump what could they possibly be
looking for here
well i actually don't think they went in
looking for documents i think that was
probably their their excuse that they
found some obama donor judge to write
him on a a ruse yeah they found some
obama donor judge to write not even a
judge a magistrate to write uh and give
them the search warrant i think they
went into looking to see whatever they
could find their argument is all right
we were here looking for documents we
didn't find those but look what we did
find or who knows what happened while
they were in there because the lawyers
weren't allowed to see it these people
are obsessed the far left they will stop
at nothing
people don't understand this is the
playbook from all over the world the far
left believes that their cause is so
worthy that anyone who is against it
must be evil must be a criminal and must
be punished and put away look this is
one of the reasons i know people hear
this all the time this is why elections
really matter we've got to take back the
majority in the house and senate so we
can subpoena the records behind this and
these other efforts so we could bring in
the director of the fbi the attorney
general and force people to testify
under oath about who told you what who
told you to do this what was the
justification behind this this stuff
needs to happen
and and and i hope we have to have the
guts to do that okay
senator i have in front of me the
national archives record administration
note that in fact donald trump
and and
the people in mar-a-lago were
cooperating with them this is from
february
so i don't know what it is a pretext it
was a pretext they can't say they're
doing it because of january 6.
yeah no doubt look they can't say oh
this is because of january 6 they can't
so they thought this was a cute way to
get around it and they could say oh no
this has nothing to do with the capital
stuff and the january 6 committee this
is because of the documents that he
retained that he still has and that's
why we went in there but we didn't find
that but we found all these other things
that we think is are incriminating they
don't know what they were going to find
that's the point but i don't i mean look
you know this i think a lot of people
that watch this program know this but a
lot of americans are busy with their
everyday lives and don't miss it every
single day prominent members of the left
prominent democrats in congress are
demanding that merrick garland that he
indict donald trump right now forget
about the evidence they want him
indicted they want him put away in jail
they've been demanding that for months
and months and months as have you know
many of these idiots who are
commentators and these other networks
that are giddy about it some of these
people are supposedly legal experts and
they say stupid and ridiculous things
about how the law applies and how it
doesn't apply it's but but i'll tell you
where the danger is the fire is here
okay what comes around goes around and
here's what's going to happen now now
one day they won't be in power and
whoever is in power there's going to be
a lot of pressure on them to do it back
to the other side and now we do become a
banana republic now we become like those
countries that people come to america to
get away from where there is no rule of
law and where everything is politicized
and where opposition to those in power
is criminalized that's a frightening
thing to say and it's sad to say that we
don't have equal justice or application
of our laws senator rubio thank you hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else